eiser only they try to give me johnson
and johnson i'ma tell him to just give
me covert instead the internet seems to
know exactly which vaccines are the best
and the worst moderna more like mediocre
average we don't do average humans love
comparing
no wonder we're also doing it with the
covet 19 vaccines
the problem is you can't compare
vaccines that easily
and doing so might even be harmful in a
pandemic
we tend to look at these numbers
efficacy rates
because they measure how likely you are
to get covet 19
after you've been vaccinated the problem
is that these numbers were not created
equal
instead they are determined by when and
where the efficacy trials took place i
think that
simple comparisons of flexing efficacy
out of context can lead to very wrong
conclusions
there are key differences in the study
population
for example age gender genetic
environmental factor pre-existing
conditions
so how do fixate trials work
participants are split into two groups
one group gets the vaccine the other a
placebo
they then go about their lives as usual
after a certain period of time
researchers count how many of them
caught covert 19. if all participants
who got sick came from the placebo group
and zero from the vaccine group the
vaccine would be a hundred percent
effective
and if exactly the same number of people
from both groups got sick
the vaccine efficacy would be zero
because the risk of getting infected
didn't change with the vaccine
but the chance of the participants
getting the disease during a trial
corresponds with the overall infection
rate in their environment
there are also differences in terms of
present or
absence of vitus variant that are
neutralized more or less efficiently
with the
by the antibodies stimulated by the type
protein
of the original bug virus that is the
one that was included
in current vaccines so while we think we
know which vaccine is best our opinions
have
actually been influenced by
circumstantial factors
let's look at an example the medona and
pfizer trials were performed mostly in
the u.s
and before the arrival of more
infectious variants
like the one from the uk or south africa
the astrazeneca or johnson and johnson
trials on the other hand
were either conducted later or in
countries where more infectious variants
emerged
and became dominant in infections
so efficacy rates will never be exactly
the same
in a real world setting and they can
change over time
for example recently we have the report
from quatta
where 50 and 45 percent of the infection
are caused by the south african and the
british barrier
this study showed us that the efficacy
of the biotech fisa
vaccine drops to 89 and 75 percent
for infection caused by the british and
the south african barrier
but maybe there's been too much fixation
on effectiveness all along
effectiveness is usually the metric for
the best possible
outcome no symptoms at all instead
we could look at how the vaccines
prevent hospitalization and death from
covet 19
because all these vaccines do that
equally well
now there is one other aspect that
influences how we judge vaccines
side effects reports of rare blood clots
have made headlines
and got people worried the eu also
decided not to renew its contracts with
astrazeneca and johnson and johnson
all this might give the impression that
some vaccines are worse than others
but again it's not that simple because
everyone's individual risk of getting
infected
influences the assessment of how
beneficial each vaccine is
let's look at an example with the
astrazeneca vaccine and assume moderate
infection rights of 55 cases per hundred
thousand
out of a hundred thousand people under
the age of 29
around two will develop a rare blood
clot after the astrazeneca vaccine
but none would have needed intensive
care with a covet 19
infection but someone over the age of 60
is much more likely to end up in
intensive care
with covet 19 and less likely to develop
a rare blood clot
that's why some governments recommend
the astrazeneca vaccine only for people
aged 60 plus
but this assessment changes if the
infection rates are higher
let's look at the same calculation but
with higher infection rates
here 401 cases per hundred thousand
now everyone is more likely to end up in
intensive care with covet 19
than to develop a blood clot after a
vaccine
in this scenario the benefit of getting
the astrazeneca vaccine outweighs the
risk of rare blood clots
for all age groups
[Music]
and of course for a preventive
intervention aimed at
healthy individuals like vaccine it is
crucial that the risk benefit balance is
acceptable for difference of population
groups or even individuals so are some
vaccines worse than others if we just
look at side effects
some perform slightly better at least
from what we know so far
but that's only one aspect and shouldn't
be the only one we consider
i think that the key issue is that the
best vaccine
or vaccination program is the one that
allows us to prevent disease and death
and of course to reduce the direct and
indirect consequences
negative consequences on the bad damage
any vaccine that received emergency
approval from the who protects against
severe cases of covet 19. they prevent
deaths and help end this pandemic
so as long as vaccines are scarce
there's a pretty good argument to take
whichever one is available to us
because if we insist on getting a
specific vaccine
we might prolong this entire pandemic
and that
can cost lives
you